we're always coming up with new ways to
connect with friends
one way to make sure we stay at least
six feet apart is to chat
car to car that's why we created our
drive interview get it
[Music]
recently i had a chance you got it
recently i had a chance to catch up with
all around great guy jay leno i love him
so much and i i got to check out a do an
interview with him from his car
so check it out
[Music]
hey lady hey what's up
hi doll how you doing i like that buick
how are you meeting you here
yeah there you go i like your car what
kind of car is that this is a 1970 dodge
challenger when i was a kid this is the
car i always wanted
and now i got it and i'm with the girl i
always wanted so now i got it so i've
been doing them both for 50 years well
not doing them
that sounds terrible doesn't it yeah
that sounds bad
but you know what i mean sounds perfect
you know what i mean do you like my
beauty
that is very nice yeah such a beautiful
car willie nelson blue eyes crying in
the rain
i like that arrow more yeah i know i'm
with you did you grow up in drive-ins i
actually grew up around drive-ins
i did grow up brown drive-ins my first
date i remember uh
the movie i saw was 1966 the movie was
the sand pebbles
and i took this girl i was trying to be
very cool you know i remember i got some
hamburgers you know
and you know the hamburger ketchup would
come in a little packet yeah
so i'd reach and i'd do this you know
shake to get the ketchup at the bottom
yeah so i'm doing that you know and i
open it i put on my burger very swallow
i throw that back in the bag so i'm
talking to her
i get the other hamburger i reach in i
get another ketchup packet i do this
meanwhile i see her going oh oh oh wait
what i had done was i picked up the
bottom of the one i just opened as i was
doing this
i was throwing ketchup all over her face
and she's like stop doing
that hello
and it's red so that's awesome yeah that
was pretty much the end of the day
it probably stained everything i love
drive-ins by the way um but did you ever
have road rage like have you ever had
road rage since you're in cars all the
time
you know something i am a pretty calm
guy and one day
this actually happened out here i was i
i
was on the tonight show and i was
somewhere and a guy behind me bb
beat i went oh i'm sorry pull over and i
go go ahead
and he goes by he gives me the finger so
i will go hey what was that about i was
trying but he does it again
so now i'm re i'm really mad
and i can size up people pretty quick so
i look at him i go
let me guess mid 50s fall divorced
fat your kids hate your wife hates you
you got a dead-end job you're going
nowhere
your greatest day was in high school am
i right you pinked okay
and and now the guy starts crying oh no
so i'm like well
i didn't oh no he goes no you're right
i go look so when i get out of my car i
get in his car and i go like i'm sorry
i didn't meet he goes no everything's
dead was right you hit it right
i realized i had just nailed the guy
so i said well you have a kid yesterday
i said you have a daughter
here you go yes i said taylor swift is
on the show thursday until i'll leave
some
ticket you bring your daughter i'll
introduce your daughter to taylor swift
okay so the guy comes and he brings his
daughter and he meets her and we
and and it turned out actually very good
but it was one of those things where
you know as a comedian when you're
dealing with hecklers you've got size of
people pretty quick
yeah and i just said fat bald
dead end job divorce and he was
it was right i was right on
i mean i'm not that mean but it was
right on every count
you were almost exaggerating and just
happened yeah exactly
that's so nice though what you did but
yeah but it was funny it was funny this
is amazing you're an optimist
i'm an optimist you are so um i had so
much fun
on jay's garage yeah you did great
people like that a lot we got a lot of
good reaction to it what's up in the new
season
well actually we just signed today to
stun our new season so
we got a look we got a lot of
celebrities lined up i just can't say
who just yet but yeah it's just fun it's
just a silly show about people in cars
and
doing dumb things i love it yeah you've
also got something else though is it
you're hosting the new version of you
bet your life
yeah that's uh that's still like eight
nine months away but yeah that'll be fun
you know my favorite thing when i was
doing the tonight show was jaywalking
we just went out and picked people at
random
and asked them questions yeah and i was
always astounded you couldn't write
i mean my favorite question was and this
is an actual question
how was mount rushmore formed you know
the most common answer
what erosion no they didn't yes
i would say six out of ten people said
erosion
like the wind the rain picked not for
president but four of our greatest
presidents just
pounding the side of a mountain it you
know
unbelievable i mean if you wrote that
people would say oh no that no one would
ever say that but they didn't say that
and that's what made it fun you know
when you catch people or scary
fun or scary yeah or scary yeah who's
out there
i like to go with fun right okay you're
the optimist i'll be the realist
exactly all right well oh my gosh i love
i love seeing you here it's good seeing
you so awesome next time we'll be
i'll be on your show again and we'll be
in another let's do it all right babes
okay bye see you later sounds good
[Music]
you